we originally were working on a story
about the first assaulters into Tora
Bora which is the Hindu Kush mountain
range in Afghanistan where Osama bin
Laden presumably was hiding and that was
in on december six of 2001 actually mark
had been almost two thirds of the way
through the screenplay I was already
casting why was doing some auditions and
we had a scouting Kazakhstan to
replicate Afghanistan and mark and I
were on her way to Kabul and then from
Kabul to Bagram from Bagram to Jalalabad
and then we're going to fly over the
Khyber Pass to look for locations when
anyway so then may first happened 2011
and we realized that film about the
failure to capture Osama bin Laden was
going to be a little bit difficult when
of course the entire world knew he was
dead but we didn't pivot immediately you
know it was definitely a lot of
soul-searching and a lot of conversation
and and then you know and then we
decided to make a move to the story of
the intelligence hunt for Osama bin
Laden it was also i think extraordinary
to both of us that that a woman was so
central or women were so central to this
to this effort and maybe that's just cuz
i grew up reading Timoney James Bond
novels or something you know I read a
lot of books and there's a lot of great
books out there I worked off a mark
script and I used him you know as much
as I could to get the facts that are
needed and then you know you read some
therapy books to understand psychology
and working with another person in a
room and we film in Jordan you know you
go to the bathhouses you hang out in the
local place has made the local people
and put your ear to the ground and try
and absorb as much as you can you want
to hold the audience you know in your
hand but keep them
wanting more and not it's it's hard
super hard actually with a film where
everybody knows what's going to happen
but I think built into the script was a
was a was a really interesting
challenging but also interesting and
rewarding structure in that we had sort
of the overall story and drama of
finding this person and the kind of
global larger implications of that there
was some ABC footage taken in in the
bedroom of Osama bin Laden's bedroom
after he had been killed and in all the
details I mean Jeremy matched the tile
of the floor and the rug and the bed
frame his we flew real Blackhawks 50
feet over-talk doctors had to be out
there and everybody else was in except
me there everyone was in this compact
and it's all real this is it's solid
stone steel 9 feet underground it took
we built in 10 weeks it's 400 feet long
it's just a monster it's like a it was
it was spectacular and it's all real
real tile the lights turn on everything
works about this place it's like you
could i when i walked in i was i was
actually really it was eerie when it was
dressed and done and we were just ready
to shoot and it really was we grew all
the vegetation around we planted it once
it in advance obviously we had to truck
in all the water and irrigate it every
day and we built in the middle of
nowhere we built 22 miles from the Dead
Sea of that sort of small and really
personal view and the wider bigger view
enabled Billy and myself to you know you
as Mark did well in the script and we
tried to help whenever we could is go
back and forth between that and that
that really helps you're shifting
perspectives so that you get a sort of
contrast built up that helps with
tension certainly you're aware that
people are going to bring politics to it
and then in some sense it's going to be
a Rorschach there were you know very
outspoken critics of the film
characterizing the film before I'd even
written a word so it was like from day
one we knew it was people it was going
to become a political chew toy one way
or not
and particularly this content you know
the interrogation debate which is
ongoing and obviously highly
controversial and you have 15 minutes in
the film where you're you know trying to
encapsulate a massively explosive issue
and and you're trying to show the
complexity of that issue and also move
the story along and show the you know
that in some cases the there's this
harsh treatment and then where does the
information come from does it come from
the harsh treatment or does it come from
this very civilized lunch that they have
after sleep deprivation is it is it the
hummus or is it the waterboarding and
that you know in entire committees talk
about this stuff but there's there's a
committee that the Democrats can mean
there's like six thousand page report on
that on that very question so you're
aware that no matter what you do it's
going to get politicized but you hope
that at the end of the day people see it
as a film and and and and and see that
we're not trying to to score a point in
that debate so much as try to hopefully
capture the essence of what went down